ich bin natürlich auch mit einer
gewissen ratlosigkeit bedachter und was
bei bild bist du wahnsinnig ich muss
sagen diese wunde hier ist sehr viel
besser als alles das was ich von bild
erwartet hat weil es eine unglaubliche
meinungsfreiheit gab aber ich habe
folgendes festgestellt dass ich als
entertainer hier ich habe euch viele
viele viele nach 1 gerettet denn wenn
einer wie ich auftritt dann tut er das
entweder um eine gute stimmung zu
erzeugen oder um beifall zu erreichen
beides oder um sein mikrofon zu
verlieren was sich in ihrer
fernsehsendung trainiere aber
nichtsdestotrotz kommt mal ich hier mit
sieben jahren der mann der der mann hat
mich ernst genommen aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass ich tatsächlich
immer versucht habe als unterhalter hier
einen punkt zu machen und ihr seid
engagierte journalisten aber ich habe
mir schon überlegt warum es in
journalisten eigentlich immer so
miesepetrig und immer so unglücklich
weil es nichts bringt ich hatte mein
beifahrer meine sache immer bekommen
also ein beispiel war für mich uli
jorges der hier bewegt geklagt hat dass
es nicht möglich ist am ordnungsamt
einen pass zu kriegen ohne sich zum
deppen zu machen marc etzold fordert
dass armin laschet demut lernen soll ich
glaube weder dass im ordnungsamt wo uli
seinen pass nicht gekriegt hat eine
krisensitzung anberaumt oder das lastet
jetzt sagt da hatte eigentlich und das
problem ist dass ihr immer gefordert
dass wir gewinnen werden auch ich habe
hier gesessen habe lauthals dinge
gefordert plötzlich habe ich eine
journalistische keule in der hand gehabt
und nichts gar nichts ist passiert und
das ist etwas was ihr im grunde was euer
lebensschicksal ist hier bild dauernd
irgendwas raus und sagen das muss anders
werden und nichts passiert jeden tag
schreibt ihr gegen die bosheit der welt
an jeden tag seit ihren irgendeiner form
sitze hier und stellt forderungen
laschet soll demo zeigen kriegt ja gar
nicht mit aber das problem ist dass das
bei uns ja dass er immer so und wir
wünschen uns ja alle also ich gehe auf
meine lache ich gehe auf meinen beifall
aber ich bin in dieser runde immer außen
vor gewesen weil ich gesagt habe ihr
müsst bleiben ich kann gehen
aber thomas es stimmt doch gar nicht
mein bild das kann man das so sagen hat
wochenlange satellitenkunden linksrutsch
mit verhindern hat geklappt also gerät
hat etwas geschrieben und es hat
funktioniert vor allem haben wir
wochenlang gesagt wie wunderbar es ist
dass du hier bist und dich also aus dem
vorgefunden das würde ich mal sagen ist
das allererste zudem zweiter hast du
natürlich total einen punkt und es gibt
ja immer die große debatte sollte bild
dinge fordert ich mache es jetzt mal ein
bild fest große debatte ist nicht ist
eine debatte die wir intern führen
sollte bild dinge fordern wenn wir
wissen dass kommt am ende nicht so
sollte bild sich für dinge einsetzen und
ich glaube immer ja ich glaube unsere
stärke und das empfinde ich durchaus
auch als stärke dieser runde muss es
sein auch manchmal in forderungen
auszudrücken was wir eben als richtig
empfinden und zu wissen dass es nie
eintreten und zu wissen und das ist die
entscheidende entscheidende punkte und
ich hoffe dass wir auch da uns
vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen abheben
ich glaube der journalismus hat ein
problem was sehr ähnliches wie du es
geschrieben ist dass er daran zugrunde
geht dass er darüber miesepetrig wird
dass er frustriert wird und ich glaube
es ist wichtig die welt so zu
beschreiben auch wie man sie gerne hätte
und zu fordern und engagiert für etwas
einzustehen aber eben und ich hoffe dass
trat dieser runde aus nicht miesepetrig
darüber zu werden das ist nicht so dass
ich auch im seriellen
jetzt muss ich sagen wo sie ein launiger
journalist der kommt allerdings aus der
schweiz aus dem glücklichen 2 2 und
bolivien
ja ja genau macht auch seine scherze und
sagt das suchen also das ist das ist
faszinierend aber es ist eben die frage
ernsthaftigkeit schließt sich
ernsthaftigkeit und forderungen an die
politiker ihr ich hab's ja gestern
erlebt mit dem kollegen ronzheimer der
dasteht und ich habe gehört dass das
lasst ihn doch in ruhe aber das darf man
nicht ich bin ja froh dass es solche
gibt sie euch ich möchte nicht dazu
gehören
thomas eine sache die ich hier immer
ganz toll filmer acht abends macht meine
an sein handy aufnahm hat man
nachrichten und dann sagt irgendwie
bezüglich dieser forderung ja das sehe
ich auch so oder so wir haben eigentlich
im moment und deswegen ist für mich
eigentlich so das größte herzensprojekt
aktuell natürlich dass alles andere bild
auch ganz toll aber weil wir haben ja im
moment den schlechtesten wert in der um
also der meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
die menschen fühlen unter 50 prozent
also menschen in deutschland und der 50
haben das gefühl ihre meinung sagen zu
können die freiheit dazu und ich habe
immer das gefühl bei vielen nach 8 und
das ist jetzt größenwahnsinn den
journalisten aber sind aber ich habe das
gefühl so lange in der runde dass immer
alle machen und vielleicht auch mal
skurrile sachen fordern sitzt vielleicht
auch mal jemand abends darin versteckt
seine meinung zum beispiel mir heute als
sie näher sagt übrigens auch die union
sollte ein bisschen konservativer werden
und ich glaube dafür ist es gut wenn
journalisten ihre meinung sagen und
fordern das andere zuhause vielleicht zu
sehen und dann sagen ich sehe das auch
ich habe aber auch diese ungerechte
wahrnehmung jetzt wird bekommen jetzt
eine geschrieben wie kannst du dich
neben sturz diesen hetzer setzen naja
ich hab ja es ist ja sehr geändert aber
dann sei er tobt hat meines wissens nie
gehetzt seit ich neben ihm sitzen
durchaus kluge dinge gesagt die von
hätten kommen können aber
nichtsdestotrotz wie wahrnehmung jetzt
man wird einfach einsortiert in eine
ecke und das dass das finde ich
ungerecht und an dieser stelle möchte
ich dafür eine lanze brechen es gibt
meinungsfreiheit gruppen ist dies ja
auch dass ihr beiden mich die besten
freunde sagt trotzdem sei das einzige
aber das ist ja das 1 jahres
und das ist ja auch genau dass er an
unserer zeit marc etzold und ich haben
uns heute das allererste mal getroffen
ich habe ihnen dann in alter gottschalk
man hier sofort geduzt hätte genau und
er war dabei
mag es halt nicht kennen uns nur von
twitter um mal schreibt der twittert er
was nettes über bild mal was nicht so
nettes ich nehme es immer war
interessanterweise und das sagt auch
viel war unsere gesellschaft obwohl ich
mal erzeugt vorher noch nie getroffen
habe freue ich mich wenn er was nettes
über mich schreibt ja von ärger mich
auch total wenn er was wirklich mit
bühne und denkt wie kann der nur jetzt
schreibt er da schon wieder sich
darunter das haben schon vier hat schon
viele retweets und sechs herzen was denn
das schon wieder und dann überlege ich
schreibe ich ja sagen denn dann weiß ich
und ich habe manches davon versprochen
community haben
jetzt kommen auch die größte versuchung
und dann erzählen die leute derzeit
unter reichelt alles ist ganz schwierig
hoffentlich vertragen ist die haben sich
noch nie getroffen aber nicht so und ich
hoffe ich hoffe dass diese runde ein
bisschen darüber hinweg helfen kann über
diese wahrnehmung der hat mal was über
mich getwittert und deswegen und
deswegen sind das eigentlich feinde denn
wir haben an diesem tisch so viele
unterschiedliche meinungen gehabt und
wir haben es an jedem abend glaube ich
bisher es geht ja noch eine weile weiter
und ich hoffe auch sehr zeitnah wieder
mit ihr und wir haben sie an dem abend
geschafft da einander zuzuhören das auch
mit der gewissen heiterkeit zu
besprechen und selber nicht zu ernst
nehmen auch wenn wir sehr ernste sachen
besprochen eine leichtigkeit wir wollten
ja alle nicht verschanzen das ist uns
geglückt ganz und
wir schaffen das glaube ich hoffe ich ja
eine eine diskussion zu schaffen die
sich spürbar abhebt von der diskussion
auf twitter wo es sollte und reichelt
dann übereinander lesen gucken hat er da
wieder hat er zu wieder vielleicht für
seine hässliche für seine hässliche
bemerkung bekommen erwarten siehst du
hast wenn du bist ja nicht wie wir 3
hiervon bild was thomas gerade gesagt
hat mit dieser haltung also dass man
immer fordert ankara also ob angeles
miesepetrig sind na ja grundsätzlich ist
mir diese einschätzung dieser aufruf
wenn ich nicht mal so verstehen möchte
sympathisch dass wir uns nicht total
überschätzen also natürlich
millionen menschen lesen den fokus nicht
und da muss ich jetzt auch nicht traurig
sein ich freue mich über die leute
lassen argumentation millionen
aber
zu glauben dass wir nur sozusagen
vorgehen machen diesem land diskutiert
wird ja wir geben dir geben einen
eindruck und gegeben auf twitter auch
mal hinweise und gegeben dass unsere
publikationen
aber wir sind deswegen nicht die die
entscheiden was in diesem land passiert
und ich glaube dass wir uns immer einsam
gemeinsam sie trifft aber der folgten
journalisten auch eben das sollten
journalisten auch nicht denken sie haben
das sollte auch nicht der anspruch von
journalisten sein dass sie vorgeben was
ein land zu denken hat aber natürlich
neben journalisten immer in dieser
wahrnehmung es gibt ja die schöne
abschließende anekdote von einem drucker
in einem in einem in einem keller in
russland der revolution denn in seinem
keller sitzt mit einer druckerpresse und
flugblätter druckt und stückzahl 30 und
dabei sagt das wird den zaren ärgern und
so sind halt journalisten und so denken
sollte und es ist vielleicht auch gar
nicht so schlecht dass diese sind aber
ich glaube da tun was folgen haben recht
es kann schon nicht schaden wenn wir uns
versuchen auch ab und zu nicht zu ernst
zu nehmen wenn wir über ernste themen
sprechen wenn wir über fakten sprechen
so gut wie irgendwie können aber wenn
wir uns dabei alle nicht zu ernst nehmen
[Musik]